[Applaudissements]
pour remettre le trophée de la pire
vannes 1
on accueille bérengère krief
[Applaudissements]
cette magnifique et vous sentez bon
patchouli à tunis une vanne c'est avant
tout un rire julien de l'adar cas comme
vous dites ici et pour le très célèbre
écrivain canadien pierre fillon le rire
dilate l'esprit pour le célèbre
humaniste brivistes acquis a dit on a
retiré 12 chevaux rue plutôt leur idylle
à l'honneur les noms mais dans la
catégorie de la jeune anne de l'année 6
[Applaudissements]
oui pire vannes jean luc lemoine avant
de commencer à jouer ce que vous voulez
voir vos proches
oui c'est ma femme et j'ai vu ce matin
donc je vois arriver de là bas et si
c'est sa femme juste après midi dans la
catégorie pire vannes thiery mot est ce
que vous connaissez l'histoire du
pingouin qui respire par les fesses non
et bien un jour il s'assoit et il meurt
dans la catégorie pire vannes jean
michel maire est ce que vous êtes déjà
fait vraiment draguer à fond sur un
plateau mois weekly le chanteur je suis
même pas son nom et chanter quoi
gilbert montagné il est pourquoi gilbert
une connerie je ne sais pas il y à
flasher sur vie d'homme es-tu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la firme de l'année d'attribuer à qui et
le gagnant est
jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
paris
celle d'avant tout d'abord merci merci